kikou les boys and girls déjà le
cinquième du tos delà de l'art moderne
c'est aujourd'hui une de leur mode end
spécial amour spéciales loeb
on a tous besoin non obligés croire
j'avais les boules et cocumont camille
coulon bertrand coup j'en connais un qui
revient de vacances et tous leurs
modèles
alors on démarre les garçons 5 6 7 on se
retourne en garde loin devant red carpet
et là c'est tous un câlin qu'est-ce qui
fait le poussin il a les pieds en canard
et où piou piou piou piou a les
attentions c'est le french love love
allez c'est parti ouais le sourire le
sourire bravo mon bertrand tu la forme
et on voyage un petit peu maintenant
l'amour est universel il me semble c'est
la vahiné du love
il fait beau on s'aime ouais ouais
donnant modène on finit comment on sort
offre attention oui de leurs modèles
alors s'il traîne de l'amour c'est le
prime du love
j'ai une petite surprise pour vous je
vais appeler deux de mes petits choux
qui sont avec nous ce soir
alors oui je voulais dire un truc a déjà
je suis super contente ici pas la
douleur moderne et j'ai pensé à un point
qui pourrait intéresser alors t'es
gentil tu penses à rien du tout comme
d'habitude ici et sur d8 vous êtes
sûrement un territoire vous avez compris
ce que ça veut dire
j'ai explosé sur des 8 et oui il faudra
s'y faire sachez qu'ici c'est chez moi
déjà à nina il reste quoi bon une deux
trois mois d'existence sur cette chaîne
ensuite ce sera
touche pas à ma d'or ans et avec qui
billy phoques alors de noter qu'anthony
excuse moi mais qu'est ce que tu me re
expliqué le retourne à gacé
mais ce que c'est pénible de devoir
faire ses gaules en permanence la jambe
gauche a regardé les boys communion bien
et on se retourne c'est compliqué ça je
crois pas non plus moderne
toutefois pendant ces cinq six sept
musique
je
la donne
yeah
les boys bravo mme bertrand et surtout
bravo chez vous applaudissez vous
embrassez vous c'est la deûle à rodez ou
là de leur moulin
on se retrouveront bientôt pour un
sixième du toast labeur moderne
la de la rothaine
rebelles m